eu
[Música]
tinha 11 anos de idade estava na escola
pública aqui dentro do complexo do
alemão e dentro dessa escola existe um
projeto criado pelos próprios alunos e
professores que era do grêmio estudantil
eles tinham um jornal e uma rádio E aí
eu comecei a me interessar por esse
projeto pouco tempo depois eu comecei a
fazer um jornal para dentro da minha
comunidade porque eu percebi que
diversos problemas sociais que existiam
também dentro da escola existiam dentro
da comunidade meu caminhar da casa para
escola da escola para comunidades todos
os dias eu pude notar esgoto a céu
aberto ruas esburacadas
problemas de falta de manutenção de
energia falta de iluminação pública ou
até mesmo de infraestruturas nas casas
das pessoas Então foi aí que eu decidi
criar um jornal porque eu não me é
apresentado toda vez que eu abrir o
jornal da grande mídia Eu nunca
conseguia ver a favela representada Eu
nunca conseguia ver um lugar onde eu
moro sendo representar sempre que era
falado era com notícias trágicas mortes
sangue violência tráfico drogas nunca ou
quase nunca se falava sobre os outros
problemas sociais que nós temos como
esses que eu acabei de citar a pouco ou
até mesmo em relação aos projetos
sociais aos talentos aos projetos
culturais e esportivos e sempre
existirão dentro das favelas mais por
conta de toda essa cobertura midiática
em relação ao território onde nós
moramos acaba criminalizando todo uma
população Complexo do Alemão para quem
não tem noção é um dos maiores complexos
de favelas do Rio de Janeiro fica no
subúrbio da cidade e tem a 180 mil
habitantes então dá para entender que é
um complexo muito grande favela e vocês
vão ter em mente já devem ter ouvido
falar deve ter visto notícias sobre
complexo alemão principalmente naquela
época da ocupação em 2010 quando teve
aquela mega operação da polícia do Rio
de Janeiro a polícia do exército da
polícia também participando e eu tive a
ideia ali ainda com 17 anos de cobrir o
que que tava acontecendo dentro da minha
comunidade com o passar dos anos as
pessoas que puderam me conhecer e eu
comecei a perceber os diversos problemas
que a favela tinha para além dos que eu
noticiavam no jornal rochas comunidades
existiam outros problemas que não eram
falados no jornal não eram as pessoas
que ficava muito obscuro ninguém sabia o
que que tava acontecendo à nossa
realidade como por exemplo a realidade
pessoas que até hoje não tem acesso a
uma moradia digna pessoas que até hoje
moro em casa e tem o banheiro não tem um
teto ou não tem ventilação então foi aí
que eu decidi né faltar outras coisas e
com o passar dos anos é altamente fui
crescendo quando chegou no ano de 2020
início da pandemia todo mundo foi pego
de surpresa Nós também obviamente a
gente tinha um jornal né circulando
dentro da favela e de repente é a mídia
começa a falar que não podemos mais
circular papel não podemos circular
plástico vírus pode passar por todo
mundo começando a falar sobre os perigos
do coronavírus a favela não entendia
muito bem o que que tava acontecendo
porque a grande Emily tava falando para
a população brasileira como um todo mas
muita gente da favela que não têm acesso
à tecnologia que não têm acesso à
televisão e não tem acesso a outros
meios de comunicação acabaram ficando
excluídos dessas informações que então a
gente decidiu comunicar a a forma que a
favela já tá acostumado a ser publicada
com carros de Tom faixas as Fundação mas
a colocar Faces
informações de conscientização para que
as pessoas pudessem usar máscara para
que as pessoas pudessem usar álcool em
gel que as pessoas pudessem lavar as
suas mãos com água e sabão tudo bem
algumas semanas começaram né Se passar
dessa pandemia e as 20 percebeu que
muitas mensagens começaram a chegar nas
nossas redes sociais e as pessoas não
estavam perguntando
sobre os cuidados da pandemia as pessoas
estavam perguntando como ficar em casa
como me cuidar da pandemia se eu preciso
trabalhar todos os dias a gente tem uma
frase muito dita aqui no Rio de Janeiro
não sei se acho que o ditado muito
falado pelo Brasil inteiro que é vender
o almoço para comprar a janta
Infelizmente essa é uma realidade de
mundo de favelado Foi então que a gente
começou a Perceber É muita gente tava
precisando de comida muita gente tava
precisando de um alimento não perecível
para poder essa alimentar nessa pandemia
mas o mais curioso tudo foi que quem
tava precisando não é uma as pessoas que
precisavam sempre a primeira pessoa que
vem me procurar por exemplo disso é
muito simbólico foi um DJ que os eventos
pararam de funcionar não tinha mais
fértil não tinha mais fácil para tocar
então um DJ vem me procurar e falou tô
com fome não preciso que comer eu nunca
passei na minha vida inteira por essa
situação e hoje eu preciso disso então a
gente decidiu criar uma campanha chamada
trato das comunidades que tem uma tem um
duplo sentido né que é prato das
Comunidades e para todas as comunidades
para que a gente pudesse alcançar o
máximo possível de comunidades também
ajudando um quilo de alimento ajudando
com que a gente pudesse é contribuindo
aqui no momento a gente percebeu também
que além de precisar de comida que é
muita gente que não tinha um botijão de
gás em casa eu te amo Dani que estava
com problema de falta d'água falta de
energia diversos outros programas que a
gente tem Infelizmente dentro das
favelas Foi então que a gente decidiu
criar um projeto é ampliar na verdade
pelo projeto prato das Comunidades para
que a gente pudesse entregar marmita
quentinha né a marmitex a gente começou
a entregar comida pronta para quem não
tinha gás em casa para que no dia água
em casa para quem estava com todos esses
problemas e não conseguia cozinhar então
a gente decidiu como a gente vai fazer
isso de que maneira filtrate que madeira
entender então a gente teve que em
algumas cargas conversar com algumas
famílias entender as necessidades E
começamos a entregar fazendo entregas
para que as pessoas pudessem fazer um
isolamento burro dentro de suas casas e
não correr o risco de ser contaminada
pelo coronavírus ou então aqui de 100
marmitas e um dia o segundo dia para 200
na terceira no quarto até que a gente
chegou a distribuir mil marmitas Bom dia
durante todo esse momento da pandemia
sendo durante os três primeiros meses e
foi quando o projeto que teve maior
alcance seja o maior visibilidade vocês
maior apoio da sociedade civil como um
todo fazendo doações pedindo ajuda
artistas famosos etc a gente conseguiu
contribuir
com cerca de
120 mil pratos de comida essa história
muito curiosa porque o primeiro
patrocinador primeiro a primeira pessoa
que acreditou nesse projeto foi um
empresário de São Paulo que viu contando
nas redes sociais no Twitter
principalmente relação do tipo muitas
pessoas da favela estavam sem ter o que
comer muitas pessoas não está gás dentro
de cacto não tinha água para poder
cozinhar estavam passando situação de
extrema miséria Então o que fazer como
fazer e eu falei a solução é entregar
comida pronta para essas pessoas estão
precisando de comida agora as pessoas
que são de comida agora não é e amanhã à
noite então ele esse empresário
imediatamente perguntou quanto custa
para fazer esse projeto que custa aí eu
falei esse projeto que está escrito
assim então eu vou transferir agora 100
mil reais para que esse projeto pelo
menos start durante esse primeiro mês e
vocês consigam fazer uma campanha né e
ampliar para outras favelas do Rio de
Janeiro no final a gente conseguiu
contribuir com cerca de
120 mil
pessoas né que foram beneficiadas foram
cerca de 10 mil famílias no total e
várias favelas do Rio de Janeiro
beneficiadas e como passar do tempo a
gente começou a perceber que a campanha
foi crescendo foi ganhando força e no
início desse ano e Janeiro de 2021 a
gente recebeu um grande aporte
financeiro e foi do Jack dorsey ele doa
um milhão de dólares para que a gente
pudesse contribuir não só com a
transformação social bem É verdade
através da comunicação Comunitária mas
também contribuindo com as pessoas que
ainda nesse momento da poderia estão
passando fome que nesse momento da banda
de Mia estão precisando de uma ajuda
seja de um alimento não perecível e o
material de limpeza estão ainda
necessitadas e que precisam de uma mão
apenas uma mão estendida para que elas
possam ser beneficiadas então É como diz
sempre o meu amigo e grande parceiro de
vida raull Santiago né Sempre foi e
sempre será o nosso por nós estão você e
Tá aí assistindo você não importa um dia
não porta hora que você está assistindo
esse vídeo faça não importa o que vão
falar de você não importa como vão falar
de você faça não pense como vai
acontecer mas faça acontecer e as
pessoas universo vai conspirar a favor e
você vai conseguir fazer muito obrigado
por tudo boa noite